hey wisecrack jared again
you might have noticed that sasha baron
cohen the mind behind ali g
borat bruno and the dictator has a new
show out
with who is america making sarah palin
publicly complain about being duped and
roy moore threatening to sue
it's hard to miss is it possible to sign
my water board
sure thank you find a space that right
here
yeah but how does cohen do it how does
he keep getting such high profile people
to make
fools of themselves on camera well while
he may land his bare ass on eminem's
face or wrestle the occasional fat dude
his brand of comedy is more
sophisticated than you might think
no seriously maybe i'm mad with this
dream of becoming
a world-famous artist just by using my
income
am i i think we're all mad
and it all has to do with clowns the
creepiest kind
so come float with us for this wisecrack
edition on the philosophy of sasha baron
cohen
but before we get into it jared irl here
and i want to give a quick shout out to
our sponsors over at
betterhelp betterhelp is online
counseling with licensed professionals
that's accessible
confidential and works around your
schedule i tried it myself so stay tuned
to the end to hear more about my
experience
in the meantime check out betterhelp.com
wisecrack5
to learn more and now on to sasha in
case you don't know who sasha baron
cohen is he rose to fame in the late 90s
for his brief segments on uk tv's
the 11 o'clock show which also gave rise
to ricky gervais
his sketches were based around a
character initially called the youth
wanker
he was dressed like a stereotypical
chaff or a british insult for obnoxious
lower class kids who had delusions of
being part of the gangster rap lifestyle
the member for stains will be banned
from the house
is equal that character transformed into
what we now know as ally g allegy
started by interviewing british
establishment figures with pompous
titles who were desperate to see him
down with the kids
but predictably this always backfired
well it's like cleopatra they bathed in
asia's milk
and what absolutely ali often exposed
how
out of touch those politicians and
academics could be it's much more
democratic you see the
than the rap scene within a year he won
the british comedy award for best
newcomer
his other characters borat and bruno
were also making appearances at the time
and they all seemed to have the same
kind of finger on the pulse
confrontational satire that had proved
such a hit with ali g
sure enough 20 years four hit movies and
a major animation franchise later
cohen is back with his patented brand of
character comedy
in who is america are these real hands
no they are what artificial
prosthetic specially designed they look
just like my real hands
but his style of pissing off suits
didn't just appear overnight
cohen had training from a surprising
place in the mid 90s cohen attended an
elite clown school in paris called
ecole philippe gallier all right it's
not technically a clown school it's a
performing arts school but it is run by
master clown philippe gallier
who was a pupil of famous mime and
performer jacques lacook
who followed in the footsteps of classic
cinema clowns like laurel and hardy
buster keaton and charlie chaplin
but before you start asking where are my
oversized novelty shoes
clowns are more than just red wigs and
honky noses
they have a pretty complicated history
that can help explain
how we landed here just remember to
point puppy pistol's mouth
right at the middle of the bad man if he
has a big fat tummy
point pointed that good
it's fun way back in 16th century italy
a type of traveling theater developed
called comedia del arte that was
performed on the back of a wagon by
actors and masks
which already seems creepy enough even
for clowns
comedy del arte took the form of
sketches and improv with an elaborate
bit of slapstick performed in the middle
by a character called the harlequin
well sort of like her the harlequin wore
a checkered costume and acted
in silence mostly so the actors didn't
have to translate for the different
italian dialects
this section of the performance came to
be known as the pantomime
by the 17th century pantomimes were a
whole show and contained a section
called the harlequin aid which
introduced the character called
the clown the clown was created as a
buffoonish companion to the harlequin
their physical comedy left a trail of
destruction behind them a kind of humor
that we see
everywhere around us today they were
also boorish
and crude because my nan's boyfriend
derek
im always tell me nan that he is
cunnilingual
how many languages does that mean him
speak and the word clown originally
meant
rustic or peasant meaning they were used
as a depiction of the lowest class in
society
he is my neighbor new subtime to the egg
by
he is painting my [__] i get a
window from a glass
you must get a window from a glass these
broader comedy moments of cohen's
character
certainly seem to live up to this
classical definition of a clown
but in those examples the clown is the
one being laughed at
cohen's humor is unique in that it often
turns the tables and gets the audience
laughing at
say a georgia state rep i'll touch you
with my buttocks
i'll touch you you're gonna drop the gun
or i'll touch you well there's a
theatrical tradition to that too
one that is inextricably linked to
clowndom the fool
building off comedia del arte
shakespeare it's always [__]
shakespeare
developed the full character in his
plays which was a mix of court jester
and clown
he even occasionally called them clowns
and while they were
certainly comic relief their other main
role was to speak
truth to power the fool in shakespeare
tends to hang around the important
nobles
and in the process of getting a laugh
they often unexpectedly have something
profound to say
and if they can say whatever no one else
can it's because everyone discounts them
as an idiot
do you think president trump he's your
friend do you think he might have had a
golden shower would surprise me
for example in shakespeare's comedy 12th
night the character fessa
is often called a wise fool because he
sums up the plays themes and gives an
honest assessment of the situation
when the other characters don't for
instance when he's asked to sing
instead of just performing the
shakespearean equivalent of despacito he
sings a song that explicitly states the
play's themes of young love its haste
and its follies
[Music]
another important element of the fool is
that their foolishness brings out the
stupidity in those around them
in a midsummer night's dream the full
character appropriately called bottom
has his head literally turned into an
ass without realizing it
yeah shakespeare wasn't always subtle
this is to make an ass of me
he's then left to wander the forest
where he meets the fairy queen titania
who
under the influence of a love potion
falls in love with him
ass head and all thou art as wise as
their art beautiful
bottom remains unaware of his condition
so entertains titania's misguided
affection which allows the audience to
literally
laugh their asses off bottom just like
ali g
or borat isn't mocking titania he's just
an
innocent fool it's titania that makes an
ass of herself
similar to bottom making an ass of
titania by being an ass
ali g uses his own asterisk to bring out
the ass in everyone around him
wouldn't it be more better instead of
having a vote in age just saying
all right if you has got pubes you can
vote
uh i you know i i would be willing to
try it in some
smaller way in an early bruno clip cohen
interviews some of the coolest hippest
and wealthiest fashion designers at a
fashion show
one of whom has produced a line of
trailer trash fashion for the catwalk
yes literally like mugatu's derelict
from zoolander
bruno asks her about this line of
clothes and prompts the stylist to be
a little too honest so tell me do you
hope that these white
trash trashing people will buy the
clothes
i don't think they can afford it
cohen is of course aware that they can't
asking at an upscale fashion show if
poor people can buy the clothes on
display
is stupid but this stupidity is just a
foil to get them to reveal what cohen
already knows so you can see how cohen
takes this classical archetype of a
clown taught to him by gallier and
brought it up to date
but besides foolishness the clown can
also bring out people's
uh less than pleasant side too by
incorporating a racial stereotype
nationalism or sexuality a clown can
reveal prejudices better than most
so when borat sings
and people sing along
cohen is baiting people's prejudices by
mirroring them
or when borat does this may george bush
drink the blood of every single man
woman and child of
iraq sure it's funny because
we know he's being a clown but it's also
depressingly revealing of public opinion
during the iraq war
when bruno and his partner make out and
start undressing in the middle of a cage
fight
we see the entire crowd doing this
[Music]
but if all cohen is doing is making an
ass of people
go ahead make my 15th birthday come on
what's the difference between him
and an internet troll trolls try to
elicit a strong reaction
out of their audience sure but they're
also hostile and negative
the clown on the other hand has no
malicious intent
they're just stupid a clown simply gives
their targets enough rope to hang
themselves with
i didn't imply anybody here is racist of
course not i
am i'm racist toward muslims but even
then
whatever deeper purpose a clown has it
should always come
second to making people laugh obviously
the first aim is to be as funny as you
can but
you know occasionally you you know we
end up uncovering some unpleasant truths
so why do we think of clowns only as
white makeup wearing
and poorly sized motor vehicle driving
child scarers
what we picture when someone says clown
today is known as the red clown which
was invented as a companion to the
original white clown
the red clown was created in the 19th
century by actors and circus performers
like joseph grimaldi
george l fox and tom belling who
obviously weren't funny enough without a
red nose and that's the image that's
taken over
today whether it's used as an insult or
to scare children
clowns have an image problem a lot of
that argues gallier is because we've
forgotten what a clown actually is and
why clowns like cohen are so
important a clown isn't defined by his
makeup which has always been a muddle of
different influences anyway
per gallier once a student has
discovered his clown
he no longer announces with his outfit a
clown doesn't need any of that stuff
a clown is innocent this is what
separates a real clown from whatever the
hell this is
a clown should be invisible a clown can
slip amongst any group
particularly the people who think that
they're powerful or successful
you want to say big up yourself bootros
buttress
buttress buttress garlic
respect because the clown isn't seen as
a threat
that's how clowns draw out their
qualities in these same people
like selfishness foolishness
childishness clumsiness
and outright stupidity
which is why someone like cohen can get
pat buchanan to admit that
is it ever worth fighting a war over
sandwiches
is it ever worth fighting a war
um yes or this in less than a month
less than a month a first grader can
become
a first grenader so
yeah if you're watching who is america
you're probably cringing along with me
as sasha tears apart our current
cultural nightmare these days it's
easier and easier to face anxiety
wherever you turn
but luckily it's also easier than ever
to find help to cope with it so this
video is sponsored by
betterhelp the online counseling service
i actually tried it myself spoke with a
certified therapist named jennifer and
she was great she was professional
firmly qualified and
was as good or better than any therapist
i've seen in real life
my favorite things about better help are
one completely confidential
two it removes the stigma of looking for
help and three it can work around
your schedule in the gig economy it's
almost impossible to dedicate yourself
to a regular time slot
but with better help you determine your
own therapy schedule
you can communicate with a counselor via
message live chat
phone or video conferencing while you're
in your pool
playing with your dog whatever is most
productive for you it's super important
that you're able to find a mental health
professional that works
for you and with better help's huge
network of licensed professionals
it's easier than ever to start having
productive counseling sessions that are
convenient
and accessible so if you're like me and
you think you could benefit from
speaking to someone on a regular basis
check out betterhelp.com wisecrack5
or click here and as always thanks for
watching guys
peace
[Music]
you